il y en a depuis le mois de mars ils
n'ont toujours pas retravailler et quand
ils entendent ça ce soir c'est terrible
pour eux je pense à la restauration des
gens du spectacle les intermittents ceux
qui sont en cdd
les stagiaires tous ces gens là qui sont
dans la précarité c'est où les premiers
qui vont être touchés s'est pas laissée
pas ce qu'ont beaucoup d'argent qui voit
tout le monde va être touchées mais les
plus pauvres vont être les toucher en
premier ensuite je suis d'accord avec
lui pour la formule de yann de yann ce
que dit ma yan le travail pourra
continuer je suis là taurian j'aurais
plutôt dit le travail doit continuer
parce qu'il l'a dit lui même le travail
doit continuer pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'il faut sauver le système de
santé
si tu ne vas pas travailler tu pourras
pas soigner les gens plus tard esquisse
qui est flippant dans cette dans toute
cette histoire c'est qu'on nous confine
trois mois et tout de suite là on voit
que ça va marcher que les masses n'ont
pas marché que détestent ça a été un
gros fiasco je vous rejoins et on nous
dit maintenant on va nous recombiner
parce qu'il ya eu un coup de froid
annonce était prévu d'avancé ils
auraient fait froid en décembre de toute
façon donc on aura été recompilé en
décembre sur les tests c'est pas je suis
je vous rejoins tous les deux c'est pas
normal de faire un test de jeudi et on
vous dit de 48 à 72 heures yann week-end
ah oui mais le week-end nous ont trahis
pas où l'on verra sa semaine prochaine
c'est pas possible parce qu'on est au
contact des gens on est au contacteur
site problème c'est les textes les
pestes antigénique combien ça coûte un
texte anti génique déjà première
question 5 et 10 euros alors que mon
test n'était 73 ans font le test deux
ans de gens qui sont tombés malades c64
on aide à 313 donc vaincre et qu'est ce
qu'on fait quand le président dit je
vais tout faire pour déployer des
plateformes des plateformes de test
depuis janvier on sait que le comique va
arriver depuis mars on a été confiné et
c'est aujourd'hui qu'ils m'expliquent
qui va tout faire pour faire des
plateformes ça je suis pas je suis pas
très d'accord après moi j'écris depuis
de l'europe et après je vais vous
laisser vous les spécialistes moi m'a
vendu l'europe depuis 10 15 ans nous
vend l'europe on me dit on est européen
on est tous ensemble on est comme ça et
plus ça va et plus j'entends que la
france est dans la merde
l'allemagne ça va l'espagne c'est la
raison et lui ça va très bien mais
pourquoi on se synchronise pas tous
et pourquoi on se met à 2012 pour se
confiner en décalé pour ce conte signer
ensemble en laissant nos frontières sans
mais si on veut mais pourquoi on se
concerte pas tout ce qu'on leur demande
d'un lycée fait la une des journaux et
des raisons dernier point quid des
enfants on est en train de m'expliquer
que les clusters c'est au travail ok je
veux bien moi tous les gens que je
connais tous les gens que je connais qui
bosse dans des écoles les asem les
institutrices les directeurs d'école
tous avec
je parle dans la rue qui viennent me
voir un peu comme une éponge en disant
parce qu'il me voir via charles abrutis
de la télé on va lui dire tiens 10 à toi
la télé vous disent ils disent abrutis
de la télé tu as cannes dire ça soit
comme ça ils viennent me parler
et moi comme une éponge j'entends les
gens et pour connaître ça c'est sûr il
se consacre à d'autres qui disent non
d'accord c'est pour ça c'est moi qui dis
ouais je dis juste une chose comment ça
se fait qu'il ya autant dans ces trucs
institutrice qui ont le vide comment ça
se fait que autant de la cnci entre le
vide comment ça se fait qu'il retourne
directrice d'école comment ça se fait
qu'on tait les choses on dit faut pas
que ça se sache
le fond du problème connais le fond du
problème c'est métro boulot dodo
point barre mais moi je suis je dit ça
et j'ai une pensée vraiment pour tous
les gens qu'on pas de boulot pour qui ça
va être vraiment catastrophique mais
n'assure quid des enfants faudra que
j'aie des docteurs ici sur le plateau
pouvez vous me dire tout de suite qu'un
enfant il a jamais transmis
coville a aucun cas les écoles
resteraient alors justement question ce
qu'on va prendre toutes les questions
maintenant vous dire ce qui reste ouvert
et ce qui va rester fermée et on va
revenir mature sur la situation
économique et sur comment vous pouvez
travailler psychologiquement pour ce
voile à être bien pendant le confinement
fait premier pour les enfants qui vont à
l'école maternelle ou élémentaire que
signifie protocole en place et voilà
c'est le protocole renforcé inapplicable
écoles applicables alors c'est quoi ça
vous savez quand en août
on a choisi dans le cadre de la
réouverture des écoles en repos la
rentrée de septembre de mettre tous les
enfants à l'école
on a on a réduit les distances de
sécurité on a conservé le fait que les
enfants n'est pas de masque quand il des
portes trop jeune ni les touches ils
enlèvent ils permettent donc ça c'était
c'était compliqué et puis on a réouvert
tout la restauration scolaire
bref on a on à vis des règles qui
étaient moins anormal que celle qu'on a
connue entre mai et juin qui étaient des
protocoles a renforcé sa veux dire quoi
protocole renforcé on peut s'attendre
jusqu'à ce qu'ils soient définies par le
milieu de l'éducation nationale soient
des règles à peu près similaire à celle
qu'on a connue sur la fin d'année
scolaire
mais je vais donc des écarts des classes
réduites à connaître des pas en tout cas
le principe de transit avait posé de
question que ces 2 septembre c'est donc
c'est sur le principe même de la
justification par rapport à ça et on
sait que des contaminations à l'école ne
faut pas le nier ça existe on le sait
pourquoi on fait ça parce que d'abord
les enfants la première des raisons
c'est pas avec une raison économique c4
avait raison c'est parce que les enfants
ils ont besoin d'aller
les inégalités elle se creuse quand on
est le plus jeune alors donc les laisser
collège ouvert écoles crèches écoles
lycées collèges où le vert juste les
riverains les facultés qui sont en
accord on a besoin de lutter contre les
inégalités c'est pour ça qu'on ouvre et
puis après effectivement il ya besoin
que les parents pour ce qu'ils peuvent
allier une question est ce qu'il y aura
de la place pour tous les enfants parce
que si on revient au protocole du départ
c'étaient des demi classe avec des
enfants qui restaient à la maison
pendant que ça va carrément c'était
seulement les ce qu'ils allaient
travailler
il avait des demi classe et justement si
les écoles restent ouvertes le but c'est
pour accueillir tous les enfants ne
mourrai pas fermer une des demi classe